Hey Leute! Hier ist Doktor Whatson.
Von den unglaublich vielen Naturphänomenen, die wir auf unseren Heimatplaneten beobachten können,
von den normalen Dingen, wie Regenbögen oder Sonnenuntergängen,
bis hin zu total verrückten Sachen, wie blauer Lava,
einem leuchtendem Meer
oder Unterwasserkornkreisen.
Von all diesen Dingen sind Polarlichter wahrscheinlich das schönste Naturphänomen.
Mit Ausnahme vielleicht von der Danxia-Landschaft in China.
Mann, ist das schön!
Boah, wäre ich da jetzt gern!
Aber wie entstehen eigentlich Polarlichter und wo kann man sie beobachten?
Wie so oft beginnt die Antwort auf unsere Frage mit unserer Sonne.
Der riesige, heiße Ball im Zentrum unseres Sonnensystems
strahlt nämlich nicht nur das Licht und die Wärme aus, von denen wir leben.
Im Inneren der Sonne ist es so heiß, dass Wasserstoff und Helium
nicht in normalen Aggregatzuständen vorliegen, sondern zu einer heißen Masse verschmelzen.
Zu Plasma.
Plasma ist ein Zustand von Materie.
In diesen Zustand sind Atome so heiß und haben so viel Energie, dass sie sich in ihre Einzelteile auflösen:
In Protonen, Neutronen und Elektronen und manchmal sogar in noch kleinere Teilchen.
Und obwohl man Plasma hier auf der Erde höchsten für ganz kurze Zeit in Blitzen vorfindet,
bestehen geschätzt 99,999% des Universums
aus Plasma.
Das Plasma in der Sonnen bleibt aber nicht immer da, wo es herkommt.
In regelmäßigen Abständen treten große Mengen Plasma aus, z. B. bei riesigen Sonnenrekonnexionen.
Das sind Ausbrüche auf der Sonnenoberfläche, die um ein vielfaches größer sind als die Erde selber.
Dabei werden Milliarden kleiner, geladener Teilchen raus ins Weltall geschleudert.
Mit ca. 400 bis 600 km/s - das ist einmal quer durch Deutschland in einer Sekunde -
fliegen die Protonen und Elektronen durch den Weltraum.
Und ein kleiner Teil davon trifft natürlich auch die Erde.
Bei größeren, sogenannten Sonnenwinden, fliegt dabei eine ungeheure Energie auf die Erde zu.
Und wenn wir keine Schutzschilde hätten, die uns vor dieser Kraft schützen würden,
dann würde es hier auf der Erde ganz anders aussehen.
Aber, Physik sei Dank, haben wir solche Schilde. Das Magnetfeld der Erde ist zum Beispiel so eines.
Es geht von unseren, flüssigen Erdkern aus und lenkt die geladenen Teilchen der Sonne um unsere Erde herum.
Das funktioniert wie bei zwei gleich geladenen Magneten: Sie stoßen sich gegenseitig ab.
Das bedeutet auch, dass das Magnetfeld der Erde verformt wird und zwar von der Sonne weg.
Der ungeheure Druck der Sonne verformt unser Magnetfeld Millionen Kilometer ins Weltall hinaus.
Aber, jetzt wird's spannend:
Während ihres langes Flugs von der Sonne zur Erde haben sich viele Teilchen wieder vereinigt.
Protonen und Elektronen ziehen sich aufgrund ihrer ungleichen Ladung an.
Wenn die Sonnenteilchen jetzt durch das Erdmagnetfeld an uns vorbeigeleitet werden,
dann entsteht durch die Bewegung eine elektrische Spannung.
Das Magnetfeld der Erde trennt die Verbindungen der Protonen und Elektronen wieder auf
und Bewegungsenergie wird in elektrische Energie umgewandelt.
Wenn die Sonnenteilchen jetzt durch das Erdmagnetfeld an uns vorbeigeleitet werden,
dann entsteht durch die Bewegung eine elektrische Spannung.
Das Magnetfeld der Erde trennt die Verbindungen der Protonen und Elektronen wieder auf
und Bewegungsenergie wird in die elektrische Energie umgewandelt.
Die gewaltige, elektrische Spannung, die nun zwischen Sonnenteilchen und Erdmagnetfeld herrscht,
will sich entladen.
Und das passiert meistens schlagartig.
Das kann man sich vorstellen wie bei einem Luftballon, der statisch aufgeladen wird.
Elektronen werden von ihren Protonen getrennt
und die Spannung entlädt sich dann schlagartig, wenn die Elektronen wieder zurückwandern.
Beim Ballon passiert das meistens in Form eines kleinen Blitzes.
Die Elektronen der Sonne allerdings fliegen unsichtbar entlang der Feldlinien des Magnetfelds Richtung Erde.
Und jetzt kann man auch gut sehen, warum die Polarlichter so heißen,
denn die Feldlinien entspringen an den Magnetpolen der Erde.
Aber die Elektronen selber sind sind noch nicht das, was wir als Polarlichter sehen.
Auf dem Weg zu Erde trifft der Teilchenstrom irgendwann auf unseren, zweiten, tollen Schutzschild.
Unsere Atmosphäre.
Wenn jetzt die vielen Elektronen mit hoher Geschwindigkeit auf unsere Gase in unserer Atmosphäre in 150 km Höhe treffen
und quasi richtig in sie reinkrachen,
dann wird dabei natürlich Energie übergeben.
In der Fachsprache sagt man: "Die Gase werden erregt."
Höhö!
Dieser Zustand hält allerdings nicht all zu lange an und sobald die Erregung wieder abfällt,...
Hühühü!
...geben die Gase die Energie, die sie von den Elektronen bekommen haben, wieder ab
und zwar in Form von Photonen und das ist, wie wir alle wissen, Licht.
Und dieses Licht, das die Gasteilchen abgeben, können wir Menschen dann als Polarlichter sehen.
Welche Farbe die Polarlichter haben, hängt dabei von der Art des Gases ab.
Grünen und rotes Licht entsteht durch Sauerstoffatomen in der Atmosphäre,
blaues bis violettes Licht erhält man von Stickstoffgas.
Und es gibt noch ein ganz anderes Spektrum von Polarlichter,
das wir Menschen mit bloßen Augen niemals sehen können.
Wellenlängen im Ultravioletten- und Röntgenbereich entstehen nämlich auch.
Es gibt übrigens am Nord- und Südpol Polarlichter, obwohl die Lichter am Norden bekannter sind.
Aurora borealis und Aurora australis heißen die wissenschaftlichen Bezeichnungen für das Phänomen.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass ihr bis ans Ende bzw. den Anfang der Welt reißen müsst, um Polarlichter zu sehen.
Mit ein bisschen Glück könnt ihr auch hier in Deutschland Polarlichter beobachten.
Durchschnittlich in vier bis acht Nächten im Jahr.
Besonders gut geht das, wenn die Sonne mal wieder eine ihrer Phasen hat.
Wenn sie so richtig mies drauf und jeden in ihrer Nähe tonnenweise mit Plasma bespuckt.
dann wird das Magnetfeld der Erde nämlich noch stärker belastet
und die Polarlichter sind an vielen Stellen weltweit zu beobachten.
Klingt erstmal cool,
bis man dann bemerkt, dass ein starkes, elektrisches Spannungsfeld hier auf der Erde mehr Schaden anrichtet,
als ein paar schöne Lichter wieder wett machen könnten.
Radio, Funk, Satellitenverbindungen, all das könnte ausfallen .
Und es sind auch teilweise schon Strommästen durchgebracht, weil die Belastung zu groß war.
Aber wer sagt denn eigentlich, dass ihr überhaupt auf der Erde bleiben müsst.
Andere Planeten haben auch Magnetfelder und Atmosphären und dementsprechend auch Polarlichter.
Der Saturn zum Beispiel.
Oder der Jupiter, der die stärksten Polarlichten innerhalb unseres Sonnensystems produzieren kann.
Und außerhalb unseres Sonnensystems geht's richtig ab.
Dort wurden schon Polarlichter registriert, die über 10000 mal heller waren als die des Jupiter.
Hey, ich möchte mal was ausprobieren:
YouTube hat gerade eine brandneue Funktion hinzugefügt,
Umfragen, mit denen ich etwas fragen kann und wir alle direkt die Antworten sehen.
Deswegen will ich das einfach mal austesten und frage euch:
Was eurer Meinung nach das schönste Naturphänomen?
Blaue Lava, die Danxia-Landschaft, Polarlichter, Vulkanblitze oder fluoreszierende Wellen?
Cool. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das Funktion. Ansonsten
wenn ihr jetzt noch zuschaut,  dann seit ihr bestimmt an meinen Kanal und mir so ein bisschen interessiert. Deswegen hier ein ganz kleines Update:
Ich bereite seit einigen Wochen viel vor, mache viel neu, zum Beispiel hier den Hintergrund,
den ich neu gestaltet hab'. Ich finde, dass sieht ziemlich cool aus.
Ich hab'ne neue Kamera,  ich kann jetzt Videos in 4K abliefern.
Und das alles kostet ziemlich viel Zeit, deswegen gab's in letzter Zeit etwas weniger Videos.
Allerdings ist das, was ich gerade vorbereite, was ich leider noch nicht erzählen kann,
äh, ziemlich geil und das bedeutet für euch: Viele regelmäßige Videos. Ab dann gibt es dann einmal die Woche Videos.
In den nächsten drei Wochen gibt's jetzt erstmal nur ein einziges, weiteres Video. Und dann ab im März
kommen regelmäßig Videos, wöchentlich sogar, auf dem Kanal hier.
Woohoo, I guess!
Naja, wenn euch das Video gefallen, dann lasst ein Daumen noch oben da und haut herein. Peace.